So I thank you Martin for of willing your willingness to do this because if you do it.
With your very special location we are in the heart of Vatican City Why are we here
but we're here in the Vatican because the Vatican has a Academy of Science koma Pontifical Academy of Science which has
conferences on various topics and the members seventy or eighty scientists from all over the world of all faiths
and now so it's a really global academy and we have scientific discussions
but I think one useful thing we can do is address issues of social import where if we can interest the authorities in
the Vatican it can make a difference
and to give one example we had a conference eighteen months ago in May twenty fourth team on sustainability climate
and the environment and this got traction within the Vatican
and it then led to the Papal Encyclical it made twenty fifteen which of course was a very important influence on the
Paris environmental
and tribal conference in December twenty first fifteen because of course the pope has immense traction especially not
in America or Africa or the station
and I think the fact that the pope would come out strongly in favor of the importance of concern about climate
and our duties to the environment has a big effect in easing the past a consensus at the Paris coffers so that's an
example where the part if it had to be can I think have a more distinctive road than other national academies
but you also have meetings on the cosmology and other subjects like that.
Where you kind of surprised that particular in this kind of climate change debate Pope Francis kind of came out as such
a strong I would almost say voice of reason. In a world that's sometimes very confused.
But I think it was surprising gratifying because the other point that came out in that
and sickle was the humanities duty to the environment and of course aloof
and sisters have had that view the Church itself has had to live in that men have dominion over nature as it were so
the statement fairly clearly that the environment has a value in each other right
and we have an obligation to defend it is something which I think was not clearly apparent in earlier Catholic
statements so not only I would say kind of the environment
and you know human beings taking care of nature was also very specific and all are in terms of global and equity
and the fact that the poor were mostly affected by these issues Yes Well that's right I think of course the things that
everyone can agree about the church is that it's got a global perspective it thinks long term
and it cares about the world's poor
and in the context of climate change of course the made victims of it will be the poor
and the concern is something which is not short term a concern about future generations because they're the ones who
will bear the impact of climate change
and so the church really has all the prerequisites to be a body that can have a real global influence on this debate do
you feel any tension between faith and science particularly if you're here.
I don't think there is any tension because of course the Church used to course be concerned I mean until twenty five
years ago it wasn't good to talk to much like Alan they have to think it changed completely and I have
and the church is very happy to engage in debates on.
Issues like evolution
and cosmology etc I look cosmologists are quite happy to talk about the big back so talk about the value of knowledge
and. It's kind of striking. For one of the previous presidents of this to carry.
A choice no matter he it was both an ordained priest
but he was also in some sense the father of the expanding universe and a big back.
So that's something that's perhaps that's a surprise for people to hear it is surprising
and he was in fact they've remarkable scientist who started in Cambridge at MIT and then he worked.
In Belgium his career and he became president of this academy
but he was indeed one of the early people who applied Einstein's theory to motif of the universe
and had the idea of a big bang which we call the primeval atom and he thought they deeply about these questions
and came up with models which are still part of the.
Folklore the subject as it were and I found it
and like this idea from the get no it wasn't it Einstein actually was rather reluctant to accept all the most exciting
conclusions of his theory he'd have like black holes for his desk
but each didn't like the idea of them the expanded universe he was the static universe
and also he you know although we did he introduced this thing called the Coffee a constant which is a latent force in
empty space he didn't like it and then the maître tried to argue that it was some effect that might be genuine
and later turned out to be right because
when we got discoveries the last fifty years has been that this force in empty space does exist yet very important for
the future universe so what do you think of factor right close really very real.
But the song sounds good to say that his theory was even more clever he was it was because Stein of course through his
huge insight. There looked this theory but its consequences took decades to be fully.
Understood and things like black holes the Big Bang
and gravitational waves which are regarded now as the great convertor tests of the theory in all three cases
and Stein was negative or ambivalent
and also in all three cases only recently that we got convincing evidence something you said something about the state
of more use if you really think about it in terms of a long term investment in good human kind has been thinking about
a cause
or a millennium Yes Yes But what's happening right at this moment is well of course it is insane as you say that to
Einstein's theory was special and he was uniquely original scientist because he came up with this theory.
As a result made me of pure thought it was the stimulated by posting experiments where you started your story you start
to say you have offered to fifty years to allude to it it had it not been Feinstein then the theory would not have been
developed for four decades and indeed it was into the one nine hundred sixty S.
That astronomers found the first entities in the universe where Einstein's effect was inspiring Portland welcome just
being a tiny correction to Newton's theory in one hundred sixty S.
We found a place called neutron stars stars the masses sound
but squeeze down into that down if you have a few kilometers
and also black holes object which it collapsed because you can does offer the rest of the universe
but even gravitational imprint for that is best left and evidence that these things emerged in the sixty's
and seventy's
and also evidence emerged that our universe had to evolve from some very dense hot state there's a so-called background
radiation which fills the universe and is a relic of the hot dense beginnings of the universe
and this is what Lemaitre had speculated about budget earlier but the evidence came in the sixty's
and from the sixty's onward.
You know there were phenomena which required Einstein's theory in order to interpret them properly
and so the theory changed from being rather sort of backwater out of the major theme of physics to being one of the
real front years of theoretical physics I read somewhere in a vigil last. Night.
Fifty five people admired his words as a great piece of art which is something for scientists it's quite a quite a
productive right because you don't want to be a trooper you want to attribute the theory of the world on Universe yes
but it was a good grade piece of creative thinking of course
and there's a lot of discussion about creativity in the sciences versus in the arts of course least creativity in the
arts is more distinctive but in the sciences
and Einstein was more creative in that he made more difference there though in science if they didn't do something B.
Would do it very quickly.
That was to quantum theory right there but not for lack of it is
but in the case of descent relativity if he hadn't done it then the idea would not have the moon which for decades
except I think Project led That's right
and one of my favorite scientific prizes Peter matter what are you going to him because.
It's a great book biologist and he put this rather well he said the difference between the arts
and sciences like this that if you're not doing science then if you don't discover something then someone else will
discover the same thing soon whereas when Wagner was.
In the middle of googling cycle he took ten years off to write Tristan and Meistersingers
and he didn't think anyone that school could not go to Deborah
and said I think there's a difference that in the arts your work is individualistic even though it doesn't last whereas
in the sciences your work is juror is part of some growing edifice but you do.
Is it individuality and if you hadn't done it then someone else would have done differently sued
and Einstein is part of the few exceptions in that he did make a more distinctive imprint in the twentieth century
thousand
and one US All of them are just fascinating sometimes use the metaphor finding the beginning of a roll of scotch tape
you know which is very difficult and then you can unroll it is yes
and so if you think of this been rolling tape particular for cosmology in the river which is now of.
Like a hundred years since Einstein's work on top of it here we have this explosion of results of ideas where are we
sort of say in understanding the big picture do you feel we are just at the beginning we're half way what's your
feeling
but of course there was the beginning of sun you know because as the film does advance their preferred gets longer
and a new set of questions becomes are about understanding the fundamental principles of the universe Yes Well I think
people a huge progress certainly since I was a student forty years ago
when we didn't know if there's a big bang to talk yet one thing we've learned of course is that the universe in the
scales that we can observe does have a certain uniformity yet we've learned that the atoms in a distant galaxy are just
the same as the atoms in the lab with I thought the case of course with the universe was dark it would not make any
progress at all but we've learned about that we've also learned that all the galaxies in the universe
and all the stars can be traced back to a common origin in this hot dense beginning the so-called big bang
and we can now date that to be thirteen point eight billion years ago
and so we can trace out the history of the universe from the hot dense beginning to the present
and we can also understand how from these a wolf it's beginning is the first structure was formed as universe cooled
and condensed into the first galaxies and stuff.
Yes And we have a very good theory for this
and we can actually test the theory a number of ways we can look back with our telescopes to objects so far away
but then I'd set out when universe attentiveness day age
and we have evidence of the much earlier universe from studying in detail the background radiation from the beginning
and you get a very consistent picture going back to when the universe was smooth apart from tiny fluctuations
and to the stage when there is fluctuations of enhanced their density contrast to make again galaxies
and this is a consistent picture
and it also tells us that the universe contains the your the atoms that we know about
and also contains about five times as much stuff in the form of what's called dark matter particles which have no
electric charge to do drak parties move around under gravity we don't know what part because they are they're still a
mystery but we know for sure that the dynamics of galaxies is dominated by this dark matter.
Are you personally surprised that we came so far that we have such a complete picture of.
The universe when you could imagine
or just saw formidable obstacles in learning about all your book as well I think it is it is gratifying a surprising
number of ways first of course we owe the advances ninety five percent to improvements in technology
and intimate Taishan I'm Jenny theory doesn't get you very far by itself though none of us as wise as Einstein would go
further because we had better as you say you believe is on the borders of a theory a very good right so going after
experimental evidence Yes that's right simply because we're there for him to that that's right so we return that
but I think that a more fundamental level what is gratifying is that our minds which haven't changed very much has.
And just as though the African savannah as tens of thousands of years ago.
Can cope not just with the everyday world to be evolved to cope with
but can cope with the counter Jew if one of the quantum
and also of the cosmos so it's surprising that the the world is such that we can understand both the micro
and the cosmic are what we have to get quite understood this has a link those together as you know better than me the
challenge of twenty first century physics is to have a unified theory which combines what Einstein did which gives us a
good picture of the large scale universe and gravity with the quantum world are you optimistic that this will proceed
or you are you expecting at some point it will be a sign for me than for human beings.
Well the fact is
when the you can just far better than me how likely it is that string theory will deliver the goods What is it worth it
will I think it's very good to do some people who believe that this may happen because otherwise it will be motivated
to try different ways of the never succeed so it's very good that there are people including many of our friends
and colleagues call working on ideas of Unified Theory his and I hope they will succeed
but I think we have to be open minded about whether there are deep aspects of reality which are going to be beyond our
capacity to grasp because after all I mean a monkey can't understand quantum theory and that maybe some.
Deep piece of reality which we just can't comprehend as hopeless as monkeys just got there you think that will ever
discovered these things or Dio can almost by definition outside the realm because Mark is probably also not the man
and that they can't understand quantum mechanics Well Lou that's why they went to not aware of these thirty
but the maybe has base of nature which we are not aware of
and that of course may mean that there are discoveries to be left to.
Brains better than ours some kind of push to bring in cities which may come into existence on Earth talk clearly your
business partner amazing you do this is. Human beings on planet Earth.
Looking at the universe do you think there are signs elsewhere in the universe.
Scientists of well of of course what we we don't know I mean I think in big we can say more you know it's that question
and we could have done twenty years ago because one thing we've certainly learnt reaches a great discovery in the last
twenty years is that most of the stars which we see are over to the rich
and use of planets just as the sun is always hit by the earth and the other familiar planets
and it's quite likely that in our Milky Way galaxy there are a billion planets rather like the earth
and ideas in a sense about the size of the earth
and at the distance from their parents star system water can exist neither boiling away
nor stay fairly as comfortable to our kind of life I suppose of habitat
but of course being habitable is not the same as being inhabited
and of course one of the key scientific questions which is not understood yet
and is the origin of life even on Earth I mean we understand how from this simplest organisms over two
and a half billion years or so.
But I was fearful we are apart as emerged
but what is still not understood is the actually origin the transition from complex chemistry to the first metabolizing
replicating structures and that's one of these problems everyone has known is important
but it's been put in the as it were too difficult box at least it's very difficult to say yes
but do you feel this is a problem that it's kind of it's foreseeable that say within the next decade I think it is
necessary yes because I think unlike the past now there are serious people working on it yet.
So I'm hopeful of within ten
or twenty years we will understand how that key transition from my chemistry to the first replicating metabolizing
structures happened I think we will understand that because it's no longer thought premature
and so chemists aided by experiments and computer experiments are making progress and of course
when we understand that which of course is an exciting discovery even the most earthbound biologist you'll tell us two
things in Tellus Was it a rare fluke Yes a wood disciplined in some other planet like the earth
or that life originated remarkably fast after the moment a bus crossed really it seems it's a simple life did you
notice cellular took longer and that of course does indicate that it wasn't a rare fluke and did happen
and so we will understand that
but another thing we might understand ten twenty years from now is whether the chemical basis of all life on earth
D.N.A.
and Our and all that is sort of uniquely special
or whether there could be life out there which could be quite different yet yes couldn't even be the same basic life on
Titan just so we would have to have are going to start talking again you're in a position for some of these questions
to be asked and asked whether actually going to build it that's right because
when we can't quite do it yet within ten years we have telescope powerful enough to actually take the spectrum of the
light from a planet around another star and get some feel for is that August in there is the surface green
and things like that so we will learn whether there is vegetation
or life of some kind some kind of footage that is just going on all these other planets around other stars
and that to be a huge discovery and as a scientist you have to you you're very much aware of all the uncertainties
and experiments real problems for you but as a cosmology if you think about a cost.
What your personal god of what I'm saying gut feeling
but your impression intuition you think that the universe is populated. Also with intelligent.
Well I think we know so little looked at so there would be foolish to lay forgive those all the good news is OK
but even that aside I mean I think if you asked me to bet yes I would bet that sort of simple life is probably
widespread but of course going from simple life to.
Life like us which are self-aware
and intelligent we don't know how likely that was because evolution abolishes debate about the contingencies that were
involved in our versions rather then i was depressed critical points for instance and didn't like to go over thirty
but you know that's right and you know if the dinosaurs had been wiped out you know.
In terms of developed somewhere also or what would these contingencies crucial so we did
and if evolution were really run on the earth then would it end up the same or would it in a quite different
and so that's an uncertainty which means that even if the simple life we don't know.
How likely it is attributed Voivod made to became intelligent but then of course there's another question
but one thing which started he does tell us is that the time lying ahead exactly said least as long as the time that
elapsed up till now the sun has been shining for half a billion years
but it will divide six billion before it flares up and go off the inner planets and wipes out
and you know I from anything on earth
and so no stronger could really believe that we humans are the culmination of evolution.
For continuing its continued and I'll be no idea what's going to happen I mean if we if we.
Think of what might happen on the earth and then of course the pessimistic outcome if you wipe ourselves out
but the more optimistic scenario is that the developer continues
but if developer to use beyond humans like us it will be doubling in selection it will be.
Controlled technical technology driven evolution by future developments in gene editing and also cyborgs
and artificial intelligence
and so you talk a little bit about I think your answer very interesting face that our civilization is new technology
was always around yes but you can definitely say no if it's kind of growing.
Exponentially fast
and I want to come to the topic where I feel personally that we are moving away from a phase where we understood
basically the building blocks of matter of life
and perhaps the universe sorts of face where we start kind of rearranging these building blocks right now so you
already mentioned. We understood living organisms but I think now in the lab we try to create parts or perhaps whole.
Living cells and so you feel this is kind of a some sense of phase transition this is a this is a radical change
and I think what did I think that this century is special for a number of reasons it's the first one we could.
Create a species quite different where you now exist it's the first where maybe artificial intelligence you know twenty
contenders and they start to compete with the level of intelligence in the hardware you know scholars
and it's also of course the fifth century
when for the first time life can spread from the Earth to other places in the solar system so this is a special century
even in the cause which.
Perspective where they've been forty five million centuries already since the earth for Earth
and there will be at least that number in the future so this entry is very special
and can you say something about what you see as future developments not in many many centuries
but say France the next next decades because of some of these developments are going incredibly fast
and perhaps we are not even the droplet even aware what is possible right now so for instance thinking bowls of life
and tolerance How do you see this happening in the coming coming years about your parents whether
or not the next person either is topics but if you want free you were right but
but I think it's clear that our understanding of genetics and I belittled to actually synthesize new genomes
and modify existing genomes is developing very fast to the extent it will be possible to always design new species
or design very heavily modified species and adapt our progeny
and that's going to happen in parallel is another quite separate development which is.
That while I was in computers from being just calculating machines to being.
Objects which can undertake what's called generalized machine learning and we've seen developers of this in the book
and they spectacular come well indeed
and of course to think of some key steps in this it's twenty years since a computer be Kasparov the world chess
champion.
And that was done by the program being made by the chess players etc
and the computer could work through minutes of this fast
but for this to be talked tossed a computer directly into your place Where is what happened this year was a computer
beat the world's championship game of government and this is another very challenging game played more the cup.
Played out more challenging yes but the big difference was in this case
and the computer was not programmed to detail
and it was a really good in the general rules then it to it watched hundreds of thousands of games
and then played against itself had got better so the people who devised the program they didn't understand why it made
some particular clever moves which in a bid to beat the world champion
and so this is an example where the computer is sort of teaching itself by being able to crunch huge amounts of data
and just the same like translation is now done not by giving the computer the details of the cabaret and syntax
but by getting it to read it read millions of pages
and then if they give major pages of European Union documents of different languages it never gets bored it just means
all of these kind of eventually are learned to translate a perfect circle so that the thought That's right so this is
generally considered it is very worried about the fact that these machines will be people that go on
or in language skills they're basically not able to tell us how did it it's what I mean they do not able to instruct us
they just it does probably learn how to do this
and then the fact that the way a child learns to speak a language you have ever considered language
when you're not able to write out a grammar Yes yes I'm worried about the machines are doing more
and more of that stuff between extremely convenient that they're kind of autonomous that they just go to wrong ways
well I think there is a worry because there's some things which are they they will be able to do better in humans like
a will
but already the the way the cost of hedge funds steer money Office price by being able to analyze more data to the
human being can and of course that's going to get better
and better as they can see tiny coloration related marketers of our witnesses that's rather let me do that already
but they do it or to go to. Said that but I think we got to bear in mind that I'm still they don't really have.
Human level general to intensity do some things and of course.
The whole point is that robots are still clumsy I mean they know they can move around the piece on the real chessboard
well as a child can there's a long way to go before a machines can actually walk you tried the external world of the
likes of this.
Game going between going to dreaded that the fifth game actually was wrong by the Gore campaign because he felt.
I'm not going to be required to do some crazy stuff so if you have to be a good something so this fifth game might be
something some pop rocks the unique human quality well of that's right it's a human's is more flexible and
and of course there are many things which.
She's can do
but of course the problem with understand that it's going to be to ensure that machines have common sense because there
are many things that we we understand. About the world friends I was told that the. Computer to beat in the.
The American champion it is.
To a good game and oh did you go call jeopardy which was yes yes and I did know this game
but it just isn't less might just that most computer did those to T.V.
Games but it was asked a question which is big enough the shoe box all down to Everest
and couldn't say I'm going to see it it has no significance if you're going to be able to pick who should block it yes
it had no conception of their day world
and another simple example it's given is that if you have a one of these robots in your home which is supposed to sort
of make sure that your fridge is stored up and the heating is on the food for you when you come home you know.
If it's the life of meat it may put the cat in the other no you know because it may have realized that the turn this
other thing was not appropriate and so one of the chicken in the office for yes
but right so one of the issues really for the people developing here is to ensure that it does learn what human ethics
and human attitudes are and which it tells us to be able to learn that those sorts of things as I know one guy
or a cusp are of course ask you know boy yes he lost this game is just a game against a computer that's you know it's
not man against machine but he said well it's me
and the machine to against somebody else so yes there's some sense is there is that a better image in our mind that we
should kind of start to collaborate with these machines
and I think so because I think Casper says that the human plus a machine Yes that is best
and I think that's going to be to happen but there's are these nightmare scenarios of the machines taking over
and of course the kind of thing which I think is not too futuristic is if we have a system of the city where all the
public services and the transport is controlled in some small way and the whole thing could go wrong
and so we're very vulnerable and one of the downsides of course of all these developments and indeed of the debate
and interconnected world is that we are more vulnerable because everything is interconnected just to go there any
moment
but if you think about this issue of we talk about nature of our money origins of life here comes back up Aleutian Yes
Now when developing technology to us again from a cosmic perspective.
Is there do you see a difference between what nature is doing what we're doing
and where I think in the sense we're to we're going to take over from nature because if we think of what may happen not
to next fifty years but maybe next. Two or three hundred years then it may well be that she women's.
Need to sort of cyborgs or become or that the electronic machines take over completely because obviously.
They don't have all the features of the human brain but they have the advance of speed compared to the human brain
and so it could be that the future will lie with.
Electronic machines not organic creatures like us
and I personally think if you ask me my most likely scenario for the next hundred years I think that.
The they will be in a hundred years a few people living on Mars and there be people who.
Will adventurers that have to cope with a hostile.
Climate
and invade conditions only question bookstores yes right that day in the environment for which their bodies are ill
adapted
and I think they will use all the technology will then have to adapt to that new environment where that would be by
Cibo techniques by downloading their brain dead to machine or something like that
and I think it will happen there because we're probably going to want to control for ethical potential reasons the
adoption of these technology here on Earth where it is if you have these people beyond the range of any such regulation
the good wishes and good luck
and no good listening Good to be administered I might buy my scenario would be that within a few hundred years there
will be.
Entities who call post humans in that they were very different from our so they'd be a new species and if they are.
Electronic
and not organic then of course they may not want to be on the planet at all they may be happy a hundred zero gravity
somewhere else and as an analogy the future.
And so if you then think in terms of the cosmic perspective of time
when there are millions of centuries ahead then the way things were looking is that we had forty five million centuries
and then for a few tens or hundreds of centuries organic civilization evolved developed technology
and then it was taken over by Sheen and they have been billions of years billions of centuries ahead
and so this has an implication also if we are thinking it might be intelligent life elsewhere and universe
and I think as I said I think them for the simple life but it is in terms of life will be
and I think if we detect any kind of evidence for something artificial.
Beyond our solar system then it is more likely to be these machines because if the evolution on this other planet
attract what happened on the earth then it's allowed to be synchronized
and if their ability is behind them the best because the we know we have some sense where nature
and technology are we're going to say that that's right so which is our current Yes Currently that's right it's if it
if they're behind us then to be no evidence for any technology if they're ahead of us then they will have got way into
this machine age and so I think it would be unlikely that we would detect any other.
External Intelligence which is anywhere like us so I think the normal talk about you know these
and aliens who are sort of by page with his own storks Maybe you heard that that's not realistic on the story yet this
face the truth currently is just the face of the evolution of life which is necessary to spread from planet earth
through the universe. We really it's only through technology that we can actually really spread around the.
Dr because clearly it as humans we're not adapted to do long voyages goes if your machine near immortal then these long
distance voyages if you want to make them are going to be possible but of course this leads to another.
Point the famous family paradox on Earth which is that if indeed life on earth was not unique then why haven't we seen
evidence for the avian she's had a head start over us and if it indeed is a serious constraint
and just does lead me to suspect that perhaps intelligent life is is rare and if that's the case of course then it.
Makes what happens here on earth even more important because it to the Master us as human beings
but it could because between Porton because in this century.
What happens will determine whether life takes its next step
and jump starts pushed human evolution away from the earth and in organic form or whether we sort of snuff things out
or go back to the Stone Age
and that would foreclose these potentials for what might happen in the far future market thinking about this.
Phase technology is becoming more important to market even picking
or taking over what we do here how do you see this from the point of evolution is there's another source face you know
which is a different God because we've evolved from simple life through doubling in selection here over three
and a half billion years but because the human beings that we need selection has stopped anyway
but future evolution will be technological it will be through border find the genome
and cyber technology of only plug into machines etc and so.
This will happen in a directed way on the technological time scale
and therefore much faster because Darwinian selection takes about a million years for a species to form of all of them
go extinct Where is the changes to the manatee and the emergence of post humans could take just centuries.
Talk about centuries you wrote a book with a tart all our final century effect I think in the U.K.
It was a final hour ordeal rather ordinary round saw looks like it's like that of a case of the person in our hour
but it's.
You dirty you talked about the dangers that are coming with these rapid developments yes in technology can you say
something about what you see as the dangers
and why is this particular century this twenty first century so crucial is where I think the two kinds of dangers which
are new to us this century One is that we are collectively putting greater pressures on the environment he said war of
those each of us more demanding in energy resources nets why we worry about climate change. Loss of biodiversity.
And issues like that is that dangerous to the planet of course a dangerous to us it's dangerous to us I mean not to the
planet suppose apart the drivers of life yes
but maybe depleted state because if if by diversity is reduced it will be a less exciting
but I'm using that cells are going to get massive extinct Yes that's right so they have to start again from the States
so one class a threat to those we are causing connectedly But the other kind which I focused on a bit more than a book
are the threats that
and the search for the powerful technologies which empower individual small groups of course we had the nuclear weapons
or to the outcome of the twentieth century technology which of course changed some global political scene
but it was also pretty close to.
Call it a very close call yes you will remember this is not obvious that we would survive to go absolutely true just as
a McNamara said they were lucky as well as wise at the time of Cuba yes and then we might be less likely less time
and of course that threat is just it a balance because we could imagine a new standoff between new super powers
and had less Luckily than the Cooper crisis so that's one threat
but I think twenty first century technology is faces with new threats in particular about biotechnology because
biotechnology of course is very powerful but we could never age the genome
and this article gave the function technology where you can make that influenza virus more virulent
and more transmissible and these techniques a widely understood by hacking is even a student sport in some places
and they don't need to shoot special purpose facilities so where is it you can monitor the misuse of nuclear technology
you can't make an H.
Bomb you know garrote as it were and it's very hard to monitor the misuse of bio and cyber
and that's what worries me that by air all by terror then a small group
or even an individual could call cause of sort of global disaster what about the whole realm of information
and where we share information our communication technology perhaps also intelligence that works because what you feel
well what we're vulnerable of course because we depend on global networks all of our manufacturing etc in this
financial system etc And we know that cyber attacks can already be very serious police
and that's going to be aggravated I think is time time goes on as we become warm water pendent on the information
technology
and networks you feel we are in a certain kind of arms race with technology between kind of the good in the bad because
just because many of these issues you mention need again technology to control really.
They do indeed it's a kind of arms race
and I think the the why I have is that it's not obvious that the good side is going to win
and I think we can predict unfortunately a growing tension between.
Freedom previously and security yes if we are to avoid the misuse
and I worry not so much about all the NY state actors as about individual disaffected groups
and my worst nightmare for instance would be someone who was an ecology fanatic who thought to Toobin human beings in
the world
and someone with those acids combined with fanaticism might say well let's cut down the number who make the world by
releasing some engineer virus perfectly this is feasible this is really feeling you know yes you feel sort of the risk
because it's a purely technological matter roaster also some kind of a moral dimension.
But obviously we it would be immoral to do anything like that
but maybe they're also a scientist Yes Well I think of obviously has politicians have an extra incentive to minimize
the number of disaffected people with grievances
or just the kind of people who do this so the challenge for politicians is much greater because a small minority which
could be overwhelmed by traditional power and the kind of course fight back using these technologies
and I think this is a real problem but as regards what scientists can do a search on I think scientists.
They're not tremendously wise forecasters always but they can look ahead a bit and warm
and foresee what are going to be the threats you didn't book I would thirty years ago I did stood up quite well you
know in that sense but I think we can for see what the facts are going to be
and perhaps distinguish better than they people.
Between what is science fiction and what is something we need to worry about in just catching scenarios
but also taking the next step
and perhaps try to convince people to take a certain direction Well I think it's going to finish people are politicians
and and here again I think we've got to think that scientists have an advantage because their work is more global
or they're more international even in the depths of the Cold War whether there were fairly open links between some of
these on either side of him curtain said science is a global culture which transcends all the barriers of faith
and nationality more easily than other cultures so we have that advantage and we share common attitudes
and we can advise our governments
but I think you've got to bear in mind that most of the decisions which politicians have to take.
Involve some science whether they are energy health environment etc
but they're not just science I don't have to combine the various components a little to do this is that that's right
and of course all those other components some of this is just citizens that most special like to be heard
and that's why I think it's very important that.
All citizens should have enough feeling for science and probability
and risk of things like that so they can't be bamboozled too easily about experts
and that they could take part in the debate if you look at this kind of conversation between science and society
and you might argue even looking back on two thousand
and sixteen it was not such a good year for reasons rights are so are we losing the debate.
I'm not sure I think a child is getting harder but I think.
In an issue where science is an important components like climate change. And G. Policy health.
Usage and ethics I think we're doing not too badly
but I think the important thing to realize is that scientists can't themselves decide
and here scientists could probably have more influence not by talking directly to a politician or minister
but through in food to the public consensus because politicians they could dismiss experts
but they can't so easily dismiss something which in the press every day which is in the inbox every day from the public
so you've probably got Mark I think is the public at large is a prerequisite for the Sultan is a dish used to stay on
the agenda especially when they're long term and global like climate change
and environmental energy so I think that's crucially important and
and I think if the public doesn't understand the basics of science then this debate card when you get beyond slogans
and the public are really be informed citizens who feel that we also should be able to share some of the values of
science and.
Actually what are the values of so for you personally but of course the values are fairly limited in the sense.
Of a stake
and curiosity etc So I don't think the very values which scientist needs to have which are the also the modded of other
professionals but I think in science there is this tradition of transnational contacts and open debate
and willingness to be proved wrong and I think we should encourage those issues
and also a feeling of probabilities because one of the difficulties in public discourse is a people the stigmas read
something which is so unlikely that it's not worth worrying about
and things which are worth worrying about because even if I'd likely they are so catastrophic.
If they happen that we need to be concerned about so one thing I'm personally worried about is there's kind of this
paradox that when science or technology is progressing we learn more
and more the things we learn are kind of quite detailed and technical
but almost by definition you're because they're new good yes not easy to understand that are on the other hand all the
applications of science are more
and more in our life so more science in the one hand it's kind of moving away from us because of increased complexity
Yes all the other hand it's coming closer because of its relevance yes for how do we deal with it how can we make
people understand science if on the other hand only a few individuals might a tree fully understand all the details
just well I think with difficulty
but I think it's not quite that bad because even though undetected details the mathematics it's after some of the
sounds we do is very hard for the special to understand I think it is possible to get over the key ideas fairly free of
technicalities I think we can do a master of this we want to do all of them whether you'd really be tried it is
difficult
and in fact it's more difficult people realize because you have to obviously avoid too much mathematics Yes
and you have to avoid technical words not one hundred percent truth
and you very difficult to be almost predictable just like That's right yes Jerry result yes but
but you can you got to simplify obviously but hopefully in almost way
and as I still bore said use of a thing the simplest possible to supply and that's that's a good earth
but I think from my own experience of doing this I think about is to understand you've got to avoid mathematics
and technical words as well particularly difficult thing to avoid which is every day words been used in a special
context and there were two examples one is do
or degenerate Yes which we know has a particular meaning in an exact Magic's going on more likely it is resident.
In America to meet.
But magic does a technical meaning and earth night is a degenerate case of a tribal cetera that's what
and another example which comes up in climate change is. Its feedback because if you want to say that.
As the earth warms they may release at least to him from the tundra
and in this image thing is a positive feedback user with positive feedback with the most people positive feedback
sounds like what happens after you've had a job appraisal come out well as opposed to feedback sounds good three dog is
a great deal so that's an example of where the technical phrase kept in this understood so we got to be careful about
avoiding using everyday words in a sentence which is a different from the like a member of the person comes out
negative just as a good figure is that's right that's right yes so all are talking about a kind of science
and being a scientist. What would you say your some of the qualities successful qualities that the.
What are some of the qualities that a scientist should have for can yes.
Well obviously the ability to understand some technical details or certain metamathematical skill
and now of course computer skills as well.
But also I suppose the motive to try and understand something
and accept that most of your ideas are going to be wrong
and also accept that there are some problems which you will never solve I think one of the differences between
laypeople and experts is that.
They people don't realize that some problems are really too difficult to some I mean and.
The balance between was easy it was difficult it was surprising we are I would give an example my own field just on me
that I expect people to believe me if I tell them about what happens when two black holes a billion law.
She has a way to libel each other and that Margaret got evidence for that
but on the other hand you are foolish to believe any expert of child care
or diet which I think that everyone has a part.
Of the understands
and that's because it's a fallacy to think that every day problems are the easy problems of the hardest problem
but as he did with human beings is far harder to understand than any things in the an inanimate world
and it's a fallacy to think that they need to understand just like people sometimes say that.
It should be easier to cut cure the common cold and other diseases just because it's common
but that doesn't mean it's a people that have a feeling for what the what can be done about carbon
and of course one of the facts of being a scientist is to choose a topic to work on which is not trivial
nor the other harmed so intractability would make any progress at all to talk about the motivation of scientists I
think these motivations come in. Various kind of flavors.
Some people want to understand what I wanted to change it or how do you see this.
But I think if you would believe this yes we want to change the world but our understanding is separate from that
but I think among scientists there is a great variety of Maine to typeset
and I've been surprised by this because you know my professional life like yours is lived among a fairly homogeneous
group paedos although with many common interests
but even among them I think we see quite a variety of personality types on in those who think pictorially
and those who think it is a question was those who like computers and who did like computers
and also those who like to solve problems in a sort of step by step piecemeal way and those who are happy to sort of.
I think in a war open ended well a lot of the government all of imagination in science.
I think imagination is crucial
but it's it's sort of constrained imagination is not it's not quite like art which perhaps is rather like sort of
composing in a few or writing a sonnet where you're trying to do so they created within a standard form
and so science is something where.
Any idea has to be embedded in the huge edifice already built up by your predecessors
but clearly you've got to make some insights.
And unless you make some new insight then
or you do is going to add something which anyone else could have done as well you find certain scientists the
creativity and the straitjacket Yes Yes What about Plague playfulness Well I think that is part of it
and you know I think find it also said that you could keep some childhood instinct alive and if I think of
when most creative scientist I know who is Roger Penrose he's a good example of someone who are.
Things very visually things not only deeper than the rest of us but Mall differently more pictorial most of us
and that he's an example of someone who's recreations of being creative in thinking of his tiling and had taken
or quasar Crystal patterns and also he
and his father who was a psychologist invented is impossible figures which inspired Esha who were already new to devise
of his new Her new dogs in the end the staircase etc So Penrose example someone who you can't really weak without
recognizing
or someone who is specially created in a sort of playful way as well as obviously very deep way I think this film is
called Divine Stein basically.
The fact that imagination is more important than knowledge because imagination is capturing everything that is yet to
be know that's how you feel do you feel that the some sense we also have to be on make aware of the opportunity to
understand something that we that are certain questions that perhaps not current generations aren't even aware is a
question that could be answered
but I think that's true that you've got to be aware that some problems which have become tractable and become timely
and work on them but at the same time you don't need to work on something which is impossible
but I think one thing which has happened
and this is perhaps something which is a downside of being a scientist is that science has become a much larger
enterprise with more mixed motives involved
and the number of new insights the setting not going up in proportion to the number of people who would call themselves
scientists and that's partly because science. Is.
Becoming more tactical more detail leader bigger equipment etc The partly also because there was a commercial precious
It's etter so it makes a diff What if your social elements to it I think these days I think you can probably argue that
being a scientist is much more well interconnectivity of science
and the fact that collaboration's are becoming larger Do you see there another development.
But of course the type of science which is done if you're in a big team is different
and you know it's certainly true that many people who have been regional scientists worked in the party who say this
subject they would not like to be part of the group at CERN way a lot of a thousand people are working the biggest
government and I know that's a quasar industrial organization
and I think one has to warm young people that if they want.
Do sounds they've got to realize that some kind of scientists like being in the industry we some of the downsides
without some of the benefits where is some allows you to be more individual
and to make up your own reputation independent of what are the big global elements you know you're in the Vatican are
but you have colleagues all over the world.
There actually are some kind of converging convergence happening if you look at science across the globe where I think
they've been eyeing changes that science has been done more globally I mean used to be done mainly and North America
and Europe where is now that the rise of science in Asia and other parts of the world is surely benign
and I think we will be missed except that the again many of the Western world which is exist for four hundred years is
going to do it because it's going to be a nation that the world's economic
and intellectual capital going to be concentrated from now on and so it's going to get the global
but of course all of the problems which science needs to tackle are they often go with problems
and so it's very appropriate that scientists should collaborator people all across the world in dealing with that
energy resources
and while you're certainly one global community just this certainly isn't because of some scientists because on part of
it yeah
but I think clearly the scientists who we have a Vatican meetings work on the environment I'm on health care etc That
part of them cover community and what they care about are global problems
and the key thing is to ensure that their voice spreads beyond academia to those who can really change the world
thinking about coming back again to your own fields cosmology us all let's come to zoom out
and looking at the universe and see your planet of the earth and we have this group of scientists.
Trying to understand what the planet ourselves but also the universe.
How do you see this from a cosmic perspective what are exactly doing here on this planet.
Well because we don't know I think the more one understands about any phenomenon the more amazed one is by telling her
I think.
When I look at an insect now I'm more amazed by an insect
when I realize all the chemical processes have to happen if it's just simply to move his leg so that the movement
realizes how amazingly intricate the natural world is and in that sense the physical world of stars
and galaxies is simpler than the biological world but of course it's got this sort of scale
and I think it's been a privilege to be working in a subject where our perspective has changed
and expanded in the few decades and of course.
We've really had revolutions going back to the Copernican Revolution originally when we Earth was in the center
and then we realized that our sun was just one star the galaxy
and then I galaxy is just one of billions you can see there was a telescope
and I think we are now perhaps going to be due for a fourth Copernican Revolution
when we will learn that physical reality is much more extensive than the delayed we can see with even our biggest
telescopes because we can see with that because telescopes to sort of horizon which is limited to the distance of like
kind of travelled to us from since the Big Bang
but there's nothing physically real about that horizon anymore there is about the rise of the round you if you are both
in the ocean you don't think that the ocean ends beyond that and do good reasons to think that the.
Universe extends probably at least a thousand times further we can see and probably must must be.
And that's not all but this that's all.
The aftermath of our big bang and then the other question is whether our Big Bang is the only one
and there is a popular idea called the multiverse whether there is variance according to which there may be zillions of
other big bands of which ours is just one
and that they may all be governed by different physical laws the laws we don't know so it could be that there is an
ecologically of Cosmos is on the scale far bigger than what we can observe so our perception of overall physical
reality is rather like the perception of a planted in a spoonful of water of the entire earth you know we are very
limited take this perspective which is all kind of making us kind of less special Yes On the other hand in the
beginning of our complete sation we talked about the special nature of life on Earth we don't know how special it is by
the fact that we have intelligent life in fact that we have life it is intelligent enough to look at the universe
and have thought exactly like this so the title of this series we chose in the mind of the universe.
Perhaps or set a mind to the universe which is this special role of us on planet Earth because.
Certainly I think of this is one of the few places perhaps the only on we don't know where these kind of thoughts are
just kind of shared are generated yet so again looking at this fast Hi Ricky.
And our little little it's a little plant all in a drop of water and a huge ocean.
What is that special role we have been observing all of that yes.
Well it will be clear they are special in being able to deduce to grasp the glimmerings of these huge ideas
and it may be the post human intelligence and. To grasp the more fully but clearly.
Even though we don't know how common life is it's clear that we are living on a special planet this pale blue dot in
the cosmos and it's also equally clear although less well appreciated
when if you want a special time he says century is very special it's the first
when one species namely the human species can determine the planet's fate and also this century when we can perhaps.
Start a transition to a completely different form of intelligence based on the electronics and machines
and perhaps spread beyond the Earth so this century is special so if you think of a space
and time guard around you know this little dot in space and time is very special
and if you spread it around we could be actually could be the mind of the universe Well our descendants could be here
just. For example much.